>> DEMOCRATS HAVE REFUSED TO
LISTEN TO THE BORDER AGENTS
AND THEY SAY THIS IS A
MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
THAT'S THE NEW SOUND BITE
ALL OVER I TURNED THE
TELEVISION, YOU KNOW I CALL
IT THE OPPOSITION PARTY IT'S
CALLED THE FAKE NEWS MEDIA.
WHAT HAPPENS IS EVERY
NETWORK HAS MANUFACTURED
CRISIS.
THIS IS A MANUFACTURED --
EVERY ONE OF THEM.
IT'S LIKE THEY -- YOU KNOW,
SEND OUT TO EVERYBODY LET'S
USE THIS SOUND BITE TODAY.
SO IT'S A MANUFACTURED --
BUT IT'S NOT.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
THAT WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP
TODAY AT A ROUND TABLE ON
IMMIGRATION AND BORDER
SECURITY IN McALLEN,
TEXAS.
EARLIER TODAY AT THE BORDER
I TALKED TO THE TEXAS
SENATORS TED CRUZ AND JOHN
CORNYN ABOUT THIS BORDER
CRISIS.
TAKE A LOOK.
SENATOR, YOU CAME HERE.
THIS RIGHT OVER MY SHOULDER.
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: IT'S LIKE A
TWO-MINUTE WALK.
LITERALLY YOU CAN WALK
ACROSS THE RIO GRANDE AND WE
SAW THE DRUGS WHEN I WAS
INTERVIEWING THE PRESIDENT.
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: THIS IS HAPPENING
EVERY DAY HERE.
>> THIS IS OVER 500 POUNDS
OF DRUGS THAT WAS
INTERCEPTED RIGHT HERE.
I THINK THIS TRIP WAS VERY
VALUABLE.
I WAS PLEASED TO COME DOWN
WITH THE PRESIDENT TO MEET
WITH BORDER PATROL BUT ALSO
TO MEET WITH VICTIMS WHOSE
FAMILY HAD LOST THEIR LIVES
TO ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
THERE ARE REAL HUMAN
TRAGEDIES AND WHEN YOU SEE
CHUCK SCHUMER AND THE
DEMOCRATS FORCE A GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN BECAUSE THEY ARE SO
ADAMANTLY OPPOSED TO
SECURING THE BORDER, THAT'S
REALLY OUT OF TOUCH AND IT'S
NOT WHERE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, I SAT IN
A BRIEFING HERE IN THIS VERY
SECTOR AND COME ON OVER,
SENATOR.
SENATOR CORNYN.
>> GOOD EVENING, SEAN.
>> Sean: I WAS JUST TELLING
SENATOR CRUZ LAST TIME I WAS
DOWN HERE I BEEN TO THE
BORDER 14 TIMES AND RIO
GRANDE AND SAN DIEGO.
I SATURDAYS IN THE SECURITY
BRIEFING WITH GOVERNOR PERRY
AT THE TIME.
SEVEN YEAR PERIOD IN THIS
STATE 642,000 CRIMES
COMMITTED AGAINST TEXANS.
SOME PETTY CRIMES.
BUT IT INCLUDED MURDERS AND
RAPES.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: THIS IS A HUGE
PROBLEM.
THIS IS LIFE AND DEATH.
HOW LONG SHOULD THE
PRESIDENT BE HOLDING OUT?
I KNOW SOME ARE GETTING A
LITTLE NERVOUS ABOUT
REOPENING THE GOVERNMENT
FURLOUGHED EMPLOYEES.
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT'S
ADVICE TO US IS TO STAY
STRONG AND WE WILL.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO FOLD.
WE ARE ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF
THIS ARGUMENT.
AS TED AND I BOTH KNOW, WE
HAVE TALKED TO FAMILIES
AFFECTED BY CRIME.
WE HAVE TALKED TO, OF
COURSE, TO THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT BORDER PATROL.
TO THE MIGRANTS THEMSELVES
WHO GET RAPED, ROBBED AND
MURDERED IN THE HANDS OF
SOME OF THE CRIMINAL
CARTELS, I DON'T THINK
PEOPLE FULLY COMPREHEND IT
SO I'M GLAD THE PRESIDENT IS
DOWN HERE TO BRING THE POINT
DOWN, THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT
ECONOMIC MIGRANTS.
IT'S ABOUT ILLEGAL DRUGS AND
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
IT'S ABOUT CRIME.
AND SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT HE IS HERE.
>> Sean: THE IDEA THAT
SOMEHOW PEOPLE ARE MAKING
THE ARGUMENT THAT THIS IS
MANUFACTURED, WE JUST LOST
OFFICER SINGH.
WE LOST A YOUNG KID IN
KNOXVILLE, TENNESSEE NAMED
PIERCE COCHRAN.
I INTERVIEWED HIS PARENTS.
THEIR LIVES WILL NEVER BE
THE SAME AGAIN.
THEY LOST THEIR 22-YEAR-OLD
KID.
THERE SEEMS TO BE A
CALLOUSNESS OR A DISCONNECT.
WE ARE LOSING 300 AMERICANS
A WEEK BECAUSE OF THE HEROIN
AND THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC.
90% COMING THROUGH THIS
BORDER.
>> WELL, LOOK, OFFICER
SINGH'S BROTHER JOINED US
FOR THE ROUND TABLE AND HE
WAS GRIEVING HIS BROTHER AND
WORTH NOTING BOTH HE AND HIS
BROTHER ARE THEMSELVES
IMMIGRANTS BUT THEY CAME THE
RIGHT WAY.
THEY CAME LEGALLY SEEKING
THE AMERICAN DREAM AND HIS
BROTHER WANTED TO BE A COP,
WANTED TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE
AND HE LOST HIS LIFE TO A
CRIMINAL ILLEGAL ALIEN.
YOU KNOW, THE DEMOCRATS,
THEY MASQUERADE, THEY TRY TO
CLOAK THEIR SUPPORT FOR OPEN
BORDERS BY SAYING IT'S
COMPASSIONATE.
SEAN, IT IS NOT
COMPASSIONATE TO WANT EVEN A
SINGLE LITTLE BOY OR SINGLE
LITTLE GIRL IN THE CUSTODY
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKERS.
NOBODY, LOOK, YOU AND I BOTH
HAVE KIDS.
NO ONE WANTS TO SEE A
TEENAGE GIRLS IN THE CUSTODY
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKERS THAT DO
UNSPEAKABLE THINGS.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE
COMPASSIONATE THING TO DO
IS?
SECURE THIS BORDER AND STOP
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION AND STOP
THE DRUG TRAFFICKING.
>> Sean: WELL, DEMOCRATS DID
PULL WHEN THEY TALKED ABOUT
FAMILY SEPARATION.
THE SEPARATIONS YOU ARE
DISCUSSING ARE PERMANENT
SEPARATIONS.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Sean: THAT CAN NEVER BE
FIXED.
SO THE DEMOCRATS, THEY DON'T
SEEM TO WANT TO NEGOTIATE AT
ALL.
WHAT'S THE NEXT STEP AND
SHOULD THE PRESIDENT JUST
HOLD STRONG AND WAIT UNTIL
THEY COME TO THE TABLE?
>> UNFORTUNATELY, IN
ADDITION TO EVERYTHING HAVE
YOU DISCUSSED, WE HAVE ABOUT
800,000 FEDERAL EMPLOYEES
THAT WONDER HOW DO THEY PAY
THEIR MORTGAGE?
HOW ARE THEY GOING TO PUT
FOOD ON THE TABLE?
DEPLETELY
COPLETELY
COMPETELY
COMPLEELY
COMPLETEY
COMPLETELY
UNNECESSARY.
COLLATERAL DAMAGE.
DISPUTE COULD BE SOLVED IN
30 MINUTES IF NANCY PELOSI
AND CHUCK SCHUMER ACTUALLY
WANTED TO NEGOTIATE IN GOOD
FAITH.
>> Sean: DIDN'T THEY SUPPORT
IT IN 2006 AND 2013.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Sean: THEY SOUNDED LIKE
TRUMP.
>> WELL, HILLARY CLINTON,
BARACK OBAMA, CHUCK SCHUMER,
ALL SUPPORT YOU HAD THE
SECURE FENCE ACT IN 2006 AND
AGAIN DURING THE GANG OF
EIGHT IMMIGRATION BILL.
THEY VOTED FOR $50 MILLION
WORTH OF BORDER PATROL.
>> Sean: 2013.
>> EVEN MORE THAN THAT LOOK,
THE PRESIDENT IS ASKING FOR
A LITTLE OVER $5 BILLION IN
BORDER SECURITY AND TO BUILD
A BARRIER.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE SAID
CHUCK SCHUMER AND NANCY
PELOSI HAVE SAID HELL NO,
NOT ONE PENNY THAT GOES TO A
WALL.
THEIR OBJECTION ISN'T ON
SUBSTANCE.
I MEAN SCHUMER AND THE REST
OF THEM VOTED FOR
$40 BILLION JUST TO A FEW
YEARS AGO.
THEIR OBJECTION IS PURE
POLITICS.
THEY HATE THE PRESIDENT.
THEIR LEFT WING BASE HATES
THE PRESIDENT.
AND CHUCK SCHUMER, THIS IS
NOW THE SECOND SCHUMER
SHUTDOWN IN A YEAR.
HE FORCED ONE EARLIER
BECAUSE HE WANTED TO SEE
AMNESTY.
HE FORCED THE SECOND ONE
BECAUSE HE WANTS TO SEE OPEN
BORDERS.
I KNOW YOU WATCHED THE
PRESIDENT'S ADDRESS EARLIER
THIS WEEK AND THEN SCHUMER
AND PELOSI.
>> Sean: THE "SATURDAY NIGHT
LIVE" SKIT THAT FOLLOWED.
>> "SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE"
WERE REMOTELY FAIR THAT WITH
WILL BE THEIR OPENING.
THEY WON'T MAKE FUN OF
DEMOCRATS.
I PROMISE YOU THEY WON'T DO
IT.
>> Sean: THEY HAVE TO.
IT WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE TO BE
THAT BIASED.
LOOK, I HAVE GOT TO SAY
THOUGH THAT THING WHEN I SAW
SCHUMER AND PELOSI, THAT
THING LOOKS LIKE A HOSTAGE
VIDEO.
>> Sean: HOSTAGE VIDEOS
COULD BE MORE COMPELLING.
>> I'M JUST ABOUT CERTAIN IF
YOU WATCH IT AGAIN IN SLOW
MOTION, NANCY IS BLINKING
SOS AS SCHUMER IS TALKING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THEY KNOW THEY ARE IN THE
WRONG AND AMERICAN PEOPLE
KNOW THEY ARE IN THE WRONG.
>> Sean: EXPECTING THIS TO
TURN AROUND?
YESTERDAY THEY SAID NO TO
THE WALL, NOTHING.
I KNOW THE PRESIDENT PRETTY
WELL.
I THINK HE IS GOING TO STAND
FIRM AS LONG AS THE SENATE
DOES.
MITCH MCCONNELL IS STANDING
STRONG.
LINDSEY GRAHAM IS STANDING
YOU ARE STANDING WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
>> WE WILL STAND STRONG.
I THINK ONCE NANCY PELOSI
AND CHUCK SCHUMER'S CAUCUS
STARTS TO HEAR FROM THEIR
CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE HAVING
TROUBLE PAYING THEIR BILLS
AND PUTTING FOOD ON THE
TABLE, I THINK THEY WILL
CRATER.
>> I WILL SAY, LOOK, TO
FURLOUGHED FEDERAL EMPLOYEES
THEY ARE GOING TO STEVE
THEIR BACK PAY.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT
SUPPORTS THAT.
>> THEY WILL RECEIVE THEIR
BACK PAY.
THEY WILL BE PAID.
SCHUMER NEEDS TO END THIS
SHUTDOWN.
YESTERDAY THE PRESIDENT CAME
TO THE SENATE AND HAD LUNCH
WITH ALL THE SENATE
REPUBLICANS.
WE WERE STANDING TOGETHER
AND UNIFIED.
I'M GRATEFUL THE PRESIDENT
HAS HELPED REALLY INFUSE
SOME SPINAL FORD TUESDAY AND
I
FORTITUDE.THE DEMOCRATS ARE STAT
FORTITUDE.THE DEMOCRATS ARE STAN
FORTITUDE.THE DEMOCRATS ARE STAG
TO PANIC.
THE POSITION THEY ARE TAKING
IS NOT REASONABLE AND NOT
RIGHT.
>> Sean: WE CAN'T HAVE ANY
MORE AMERICANS BEING KILLED
BY PEOPLE THAT DIDN'T
RESPECT OUR LAWS AND
SOVEREIGNTY.
AND THIS OPIOID EPIDEMIC,
THOSE DRUGS THAT HAVE FLOWN
INTO THIS COUNTRY THEY ARE
GOING TO EVERY SMALL TOWN
AND BIG CITY ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY AND 90% OF IT IS
FROM RIGHT OVER THERE.
THE HEROIN AND FENTANYL.
>> HEROIN AND FENTANYL YOU
ARE RIGHT, MORE THAN 70,000
PEOPLE DIED OF DRUG
OVERDOSES.
A LOT OF THAT WAS OPIOIDS
COMING FROM ACROSS THE
BORDER.
AND AS YOU SAID, SEAN, 90%
OF THE HEROIN COMING FROM
MEXICO.
SO THIS IS A HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS.
AND IT IS A NATIONAL
SECURITY CRISIS.
>> Sean: LIFE AND DEATH?